[Music]
the first few weeks you get your butt
kicked is still training I got to hell
week hell vixen hunt 30 hours of
continuous training you might get two
hours of sleep
in my first hell week early on I got
injured I got rolled back to day one
week one started up again I went through
that complete hell week after that hell
week or during that whole week I
actually broke my knee so I got through
hell week with a broken knee and after
that I kept on running on it kept on
running kept on doing things I couldn't
move it so I got rolled back again and
had to start back day 1 week 1 again and
this time they said to me you're only
going to get one more chance to go
through no matter if you get injured no
matter what happens only one more chance
so I had stress fractures shin splints I
had several injury had a broken rib had
several injuries starting my third hell
week but through this period of time I
was developing this thing called my own
personal cookie jar things that went
through in my life that I overcame
whether they be positive things negative
things whatever it was I was still here
I was overcoming them and I used this
cookie jar for me to get through my my
third and last time going through Navy
SEAL training so when things got hard
for me I was able to go in my mentor
cookie jar and remember hey I survived
what my dad did to me hey I survived
with the kids at school didn't me
because what happens is in hell we can
instill training they want to make you
panicked they were put you in a
situation of stress they they want you
to question your your very motives of
being insolent they weren't a question
why are you here they want to put you in
a dark spot that makes you question your
own sanity and they do that very well
and if you don't have the quite like the
proper tools you're going to quit and in
that one second you make the worst
decision of your life because you cannot
calm yourself down and in that one
second what happens is you start to
think very negatively your mind
always choose the path of least
resistance we put so much stuff in our
brain our brain gets overloaded so it
wants to choose the path of path of
least resistance we have to train our
minds to choose the path of most
resistance and so what I did was I
realized through my whole life was that
I would get spastic in that one second
I had nothing to control I had no end
result I had no feeling of victory to
kind of pull from in this one second so
I would quit things I would give up and
the dialogue in my head in that one
second would be very negative I had to
find why I wanted to be here if you
found out why you want to be somewhere
when you're in that situation of wanting
to quit what happens is the questions
that come to you are the proper
questions how can I get through this how
can I make this work for me if you don't
have the proper purpose and while you're
somewhere the questions that come to
your mind are we shouldn't be here this
is dumb the water is too cold I can go
home and have a good meal I shouldn't be
subjecting myself to this kind of
torture but when you find out in life
why you want to be somewhere the
questions are more of how can I get
through this versus why am I here how
can I versus why so my my dialogue was
proper I had the cookie jar I was able
to go through and wake myself up because
even the hardest people in the world
they forget who they are when times get
bad that mental cookie jar is where you
can go through and kind of remind
yourself okay I went through three hell
weeks I was in two whole weeks I got
through them I got through this I got
through that so in those bad times you
you remind yourself versus panicking and
quitting so I learned all these
different kind of mind games
because that's all life is is one big
game it's one big game you have to learn
and have control over your own thoughts
if you can't control your own thoughts
and you have negative thoughts in there
you have to make a negative a positive
to get through everything in life and I
started to learn how to do this
versus making a negative a negative I
made a negative a positive I got through
SEAL training I got through that went on
to be even more than that still training
weren't enough Navy SEALs weren't enough
I wanted to find more and more and more
because I discovered another spot in my
mind that I realized I could do anything
I set my mind to
so I went on to go and start you know I
started running I started doing these
different pull-up records started
continue to go further and further and
further to see what the limits were I in
that and I realized people don't have
limits we put limits on ourselves and
that's why you know that's why I created
for myself
[Music]